many eons ago the universe was born
within the confines of
the panel
a world with physics and law and order
and some retcons sometimes but don't
think about those too hard
this is the reality where we reside
bogged down by the paltry sciences of
our unimaginative forefathers tethered
by lame [ __ ] like gravity and needing to
breathe air and laws against public
urination but there exists a place where
we need not worry about any of these
a place where you can jump and just keep
going until your body expires 600 miles
off the surface of the earth
a place where you can relieve yourself
in the movie theater while watching free
guy for the third time and ryan reynolds
himself will personally congratulate you
on a job well done
this realm of freedom and physics
defying horror is known only as
the gutter space
the only pop culture news show that will
appear right behind you if you say its
name five times in a mirror obligatory
thoughts on this i guess
i uh i hope these pre-rendered team
takedowns translate to some in-game
animations the two of you can do is
potter and milhouse oh but it's captured
on ps5 it's not pre-running shut the
hell up before i turn you into a shiny
puddle on the floor of a construction
site [ __ ] ah you know what those webs
don't connect to that guy's feet very
good this might actually be gameplay
because they would have fixed that if
this was a cg tray i stand corrected i
saw something stupid which means it's
gameplay cause gameplay always looks
stupid in every game ever and that's why
we love it that's certainly gotta be
craven's voice in the trailer but much
like the original game's heavy use of mr
negative in the promotions i think he's
a bit of a red herring for marketing and
the real villain is someone bigger like
green goblin and of course please don't
be harry osborne please don't be harry
osborn please don't be harry osborn okay
i know it's harry osborne but i
i i don't like it tony todd voicing
venom is just that's a good choice oh
i think they gave peter even more silly
robot legs than last time to distinguish
him in gameplay for miles a bit those
look a little octopussy so they might be
the t's superior spider-man is on the
horizon or just to tie it in with the
movies because brand synergy
i mean there's not really a whole bunch
of other things to talk about in that i
mean it's a really short teaser you
think venom would be playable i don't
think he's gonna be playable i think
they're
they don't want three playable spider
people
sad god dad is back with his god boy
i really like how the gameplay looks in
this just more of what we got last time
but with extra polish and moves and more
mechanics i'm a big fan of the god of
war series so i'm very excited to play
this one for sure but let's not forget
the saddest dad of them all
the best there is and what he does
drunken bar fights high profile
assassinations and hitting on
spider-man's wife
insomniac is also making a wolverine
game which is a complete shocker because
no one's cared about wolverine for like
five years and i missed him so much
if this plays anything like the x-men
origins game then it'll be sick as [ __ ]
i hope it's a little bit more bloody and
mature than spider-man though also they
better get steve bloom to do the voice
out of nowhere still shaken up
now i know there was rumors about a troy
baker daredevil game
but uh
i don't know i i feel like more
interested in the wolverine thing
because that'll be different because
daredevil is a man in a tight costume
who does kung fu and swings around
and also i'm just tired of hearing troy
baker in every single video game ever if
they ever made a cartoon about my life
trey baker would voice my dad and my
cousin and my uncle and me and no one
would be able to tell his range is
amazing the trailer for spider-man 4
slash the amazing spider-man 3 dropped
after an unfinished version was leaked
on instagram with a phone screen
recording a phone screen recording
it's like one of those infinite mirror
elevators that's really uncomfortable to
be in
i feel like the moment would have been
more hype had it not been spoiled by doc
ock himself and about 500 other people
earlier this year but i suppose that's
what happens when you don't market your
movie at all until three months before
release because people start to get
antsy and start spilling [ __ ] or they
get asked about it and have to give
really confusing non-answers that equate
to that austin powers joke where it's
just a sentence with subtitles that say
yes look at andrew garfield babbling and
trying his hardest not to spill the
beans like like listen i can't speak for
anything else but for myself sure like
like they might be doing something
but er
ain't none like i ain't got a call we're
on to you andrew you beautiful hunk of
i can't show that leaked clip of toby
and andrew hanging out on a blue screen
though i might get in trouble for that
one but it exists it's out there at
least the official trailer came out so i
can actually show something on screen
instead of blurred out screen caps of
the already blurry leaked trailer
everything's so unclear i feel like i'm
as drunk as sony's marketing i just put
the whole movie out on youtube in three
minute chunks who gives a [ __ ] if you
want to fund my channel as well as
buying stupid dumbass video game skins
that cost too much for my stupid dumbass
friend jacob because he does all the
video thumbnails and makes drawings for
me and stuff and i gotta pay my
employees or else they'll form a three
person union then consider donating to
my patreon since it's only a dollar we
got some new behind-the-scenes stuff
going up on there soon for you volition
games has announced that they're
rebooting the saints row franchise and
it's releasing in february they decided
to tone it down to being a slightly
wackier gta clone again instead of the
infinite alien robot shark jump that was
the previous two games where
you're the president with super powers
and there's dubstep guns and they live
references and the earth explodes and
hell
i feel like every video game now either
looks like hyper realism or they have
this semi-cartoony fortnite art style
i miss cell shading and speaking of
another day another marvel game that
looks like marvel heroes online or
marvel future fight or ultimate alliance
3 or contest of champions there's
clips of all three of those
and they're not in the right order of
how i said them but you can't
distinguish them visually these games
all start to blend together in my memory
because they look so similar visually
and now we can add midnight suns to the
pile it's an x-com style game starring
marvel characters and apparently a
completely original character made just
for the game with the completely
original name
the hunter
they've really spent a lot of time
thinking of that one i'm assuming they
won't force you to play as only the
custom character and will give you the
option to be everyone because that
didn't work well for x-men destiny look
at all these cool superheroes don't you
want to play as them
no well you're the creator character
shut the [ __ ] up i don't want to be some
deviantart oc with a hairstyle that's
only kind of close to the one i wanted
because they only have four to choose
from i want to be ghost rider and blade
fighting
uh
lilith the mother of all demons what is
this the ps2 ghost rider game
cross promotion [ __ ] anyway this
doesn't really look like my sort of game
because card based you yucky yucky
although i do tip my hat to whatever
boring weird nerds like card based video
games and have fun with those this one's
for you guys who are assuredly named
dwight blake or hot stimpy shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] this
one's for you guys who are assuredly
named either dwight blake or howard
meanwhile in the world of comics
[ __ ] all that the cowboy bebop netflix
adaptation released new images that are
a mixed bag the set design looks great
jet black's costume is awesome although
he's added to the unfortunate ranks of
characters with black in their name that
are cast with a black actor so it feels
like they're a 70s comic book character
spike looks like a guy cosplaying his
spike because his suit color is too
bright he needs a slightly darker blue
and a 70-30 leg to torso ratio and then
he'll be perfect and faye valentine
looks like a perfectly functional and
reasonable rendition of that outfit it's
got all the same parts the thigh highs
the stockings the boots the shorts the
orange vest top
for everyone on the internet saying that
she needed to be wearing this instead
you may argue this but you must first
pass the trial of wearing that outfit
yourself and completing an obstacle
course of running and jumping and
fighting without having a horrendous
wardrobe malfunction where your dick
pops out that would slow down a busy tv
set where they have to shoot things on a
tight schedule if you can do that
successfully then you're right in this
costume is bad get back to me when you
accomplish this and i will give you a
medal and a chris high five fortnite's
new season is starting with
[Applause]
[Music]
i should have guessed it would have been
him sooner because the rule for video
game crossovers is usually who has a new
movie or season coming out because then
licensing out the character can be
justified as a playable advertisement
for other stuff
this applies to mortal kombat and dead
by daylight guest characters in most
cases too
that's how it works then i think we're
about due for a spider-man skin sooner
or later definitely doctor strange
probably those boring looking [ __ ]
from eternals and as a wild card let's
say neo might show up just for the hell
of it too
i for one think that it would be really
funny if those supposed rumors are true
and we get a [ __ ] naruto who's even
talking about naruto in the year of our
lord 2021 are you talking about naruto
not not neruto how do you say his name
all right his name is borodo's dad i
forgot sonic colors hd collection by
konami released with all the fog
graphics taken out and all the voices
dubbed by troy baker and the edges of
the map showing because the game was
meant to only be in four by three in all
seriousness though i don't care much
about this this sonic thing but ben and
jacob pressured me to talk about this so
here we are there's some really horrible
bugs in the game and then everyone
thought it was just some guy playing on
a shitty emulator for a bit and then
they weren't mad but it turns out
everyone is having bugs not just
emulator guy so they were re-mattified
again
for some reason sonic just has the
shittiest luck of any older franchise
except maybe comic zone we need a remake
of comics zone guys come on
lego star wars uh got um
delayed i think
there's other news stories i like
deleted them though um what else
happened i'm just gonna
uh try to remember what the news was i
forget um
oh the wolverine game
no i already talked about that that's in
the script what am i am i [ __ ] drunk
that's it for this month weeks episode
of gut wrenching sadness let's hope it
does better in views than the last one
because if it doesn't this show is
cancelled and you'll make ben cry
don't let ben down [ __ ]
[Music]
you